it's been six weeks since I was last in
Chelmsford and I've heard rumors that
something strange has been going on at
the Saracens head cafe bar
or hand assassins head in the week I
spent at the place it didn't take long
to suss out that D stood for dreadful
and for as long as I've got a hole in my
butt big boy those [ __ ] potatoes have
been in a deep fat fryer the owners were
in dire straits if I don't do something
drastic then you know this business will
call down the pan and the staff were
dysfunctional now on stop being a
stubborn [ __ ] French bastard we need
to turn their attitudes round and if I
can get this place back on track over
the longest seven days of my life we
injected some passion into the food and
got the team eating out of each other's
hands tasting it it wasn't perfect get
back to work in two minutes
but already felt a saracens cafe bar was
well on the road to recovery all forever
well done that was [ __ ] Axl
the latest news from inside is
unbelievable I thought things couldn't
get any worse but they just have and God
has strange I mean really really strange
um
Israel's no longer there the place has
gone into receivership she said two
weeks ago it doesn't belong to him
the brewery of taking it back and he's
been kicked out the brewery has put the
lease of the place up for sale and
Israel and Tara are out on their ears
ironically the one person I suspect it
might not be here is here
Philip Blais executive chef
extraordinaire it's a very very sad you
know well sure Larry told um total shock
yeah and everything you put into it and
what the guy's done and just all gone
down the drain basically you're looking
very clean obviously not making many
club sandwiches it was magic we I it's
one of the best summer
what better the khatma sure no more
tears better a better salad on the
continously what's coming out the
quickest the club Sam the club sandwich
so it appears that things were really
starting to happen at the place after I
left and the food sales were on the up
hello Israel no I did not expect to see
you here you know that but it seems it
was too little too late for Israel and
Tara oh [ __ ] yeah well are you feeling
alright yeah it was our last chance to
get it to get it together and with it
the town was busing with with Saracens
head being able to produce the quality
of the food we were producing nice
simple yeah before Cameron anus it was
delicious yeah it was perfect
they didn't have long to reap the
benefits shortly after I left the
brewery took the business out of Israel
and Tara's hands and then it just
happened on the spur of the moment you
at work and all of a sudden man well we
went we didn't even know what we're
going to be us for the keys just what is
mortgage all at the wrong time
you're out yeah on your ass you're seven
months pregnant
ain't multiple eight months pregnant I
mean this is not the kind of predicament
I know I expected to see um what did you
lose
Israel off of signor than I did but mine
was inheritance from my mother and my
grandmother the fact that I was naive
and I didn't know how corporate big
Nationals work and the world of the
accountants and the solicitors and all
that crap and doesn't know anything
about I know how to serve people I know
how to make them smile I know how to
deal with a complaint I know how to deal
with the kitchen I don't know how to
deal with business in transactions of
their matter yeah and that's where he
hurt you love you're leaving I feel so
sorry for them and I still can't quite
believe what's happened good luck the
baby
take care Israel and Tara had generally
thought they could keep the business
going right
but sadly after calling the spokesperson
for the brewery it all becomes crystal
clear okay thank you um sounds now like
the brewery we're only acting in the
best interest by accepting the highest
bid and I think Israel's be slightly
naive no matter how good the food is
you've really got to understand every
aspect of your business and the areas
you don't understand seek advice before
you get [ __ ]
you